تترقب امهات الاطفال بمستشفى الضعين شرقي
دارفور بخوف شديد لحظه انقطاع الكهرباء
فهي تعني نهايه الحياه للاطفال حديثيه
الولاده
المعارك بين الجيش والدعم السريع ادت الى
انعدام الاكسجين القادم من الخرطوم الامر
الذي صعب من عمليته انقاذ الاطفال ويسعى
في حياتهم والله معاناتنا مع الكهرباء
والاكسجين صعبه لذلك شديده حتى بتؤدي
الوفاه اطفال الليله الصباح طفل بسبب
الاكسجين امس انا الطفله دي والله
لازعفناها بره في الاحياء حتى يلا بعد
التحقنا بقى هنا في المستشفى بعد ثلاثه
ولا اربع ساعات
اكثر من ثلاثين طفلا ماتوا حتى الان منذ
بدايه الاحداث ولا حلول تلوح في الافق مع
استمرار القتال وشح الوقود بالبلاد واقع
يعد الاكثر تعقيدا للقائمين على امر صحه
هنا خاصه قسم الاطفال ما عندنا نحن مولدات
بالنسبه للاكسجين وما عندنا الاكسجين في
اسطوانات فمن نعتمد على جهاز مولد بالنسبه
يعتمد على الكهرباء
فعدم توفر انقطاع التيار الكهربائي في
اليوم اكثر من 12 ساعه وما في مخزون وقود
كافي وين كان موجود برضو البابور بتاع
المستشفى المولد ما بيشتغل اكثر من اربعه
خمسه ساعات متواصله فبعض الاطفال بيكونوا
محتاجين لاكسجين متواصل فلما يحصل انقطاع
بالنسبه للتيار الكهربائي فالمولدات
بتاعته بتاعه الاكسجين الموجوده بتعتمد
الكهرباء كلها بتتوقف وبتسوق حاله الاطفال
فعندنا يعني كميه من الوفيات كانت الايام
اللي فاتت نتيجه للاكسجين
تخفيفا للمعاناه شكلت المبادره الشبابيه
بالضعين غرفه للطوارئ تهدف الى المساهمه
في تحسين الاوضاع الانسانيه
بشراكه مع السلطات الصحيه بالتركيز على
الاطفال بالمستشفى فازلين جهود كبيره
للتواصل مع المنظمات العامه في مجالات
الصحيه لتوفير يعني الادويه للاطفال وخاصه
فيما يتعلق بالاكسجين ايضا عندنا اتجاهين
نقدم يعني خدمه فيما يتعلق بالعمل الطاري
بالتعاون مع الجهات ذات الاختصاص وتتصدر
شرقيو دارفورد بحسب منظمه الصحه العالميه
ولايات السودان في قضيه وفاه الاطفال
حديثي الولاده يعود ذلك لعوامل عديده من
ضمنها عدم وجود عنبر خاص للاطفال الصغار
القتال الدائر في السودان حتى الان ادى
الى وفاته عشرات الاطفال ومن لم يمر
بالرصاص ماذا بنقص الاكسجين وانقطاع
الكهرباء لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات